Sally Carson's never driven a mini
excavator like this before even though
back home in the Kurdish region of iraq
he worked as a gardener refugee sally
arrived in germany five months ago with
his wife and two children since the
beginning of april he's been on a
gardening and landscaping course in the
town of Valentin Westphalia it's a new
task for me but I'd like to learn and to
work as a gardener and so on 20 refugees
from Syria Afghanistan Eritrea and other
countries have been given a place on the
work in nature course it lasts for 11
months yes we focus the main thing is to
get them started early I love to get all
the refugees with a decent chance of
getting residents back into daily
routines or learning them we want to
highlight opportunities and prevent a
downward spiral the training center
works closely with the local labor
agencies and the region's gardening and
landscaping 20 companies from the area
have already agreed to offer internships
the company's hope that the people they
take on will also get residence permits
one thing is really important for our
small and mid-sized companies and that's
being certain that when a refugee is
started an apprenticeship they'll also
be allowed to finish it and to take a
job afterwards and the new integration
law just passed by the government offers
this and we're very much in favor of it
westphalian czar very proud of their
gardens as a result a lot of landscape
gardening companies are working
throughout the region and they urgently
need qualified staff until now labor
agencies had to check first to see if
there wasn't any qualified Germans
available to fill the position
you can optionally we can respond faster
and get these people into work faster
that's a signal to employers now we can
tell them you've got a new worker and
they can start immediately it used to be
very different Sally Carson's already
been offered a full apprenticeship but
he knows he's got some other work to do
as well I want to learn to speak German
carefully about mark I like speaking it
and I like work I like work at the
moment the pilot project is also giving
the refugee group lessons in German and
familiarization with their new country
bit by bit the practical instruction is
also expanding if all goes well Sally
and the others should all get an
apprenticeship as landscape gardeners
and hopefully a job as well